Thank you very much.
I think you're
in the Christmas spirit.
Are you in the--
Is that what this is?
I think everybody is.
I tell you, I--
Yesterday, I found
my elf on a shelf
passed out next to my vape pen.
(LAUGHTER)
Something's going on.
But... And it's Hanukkah.
How about
any of you celebrating...
All right.
(CHEERING, APPLAUSE)
So those people, you know,
those people like in the Midwest
who don't know--
No, I'm kidding.
There's Jews everywhere.
Endangered everywhere,
but they're everywhere.
(LAUGHTER)
But Hanukkah is a celebrate--
it's a festival celebrating
the Jews' recovery
of the city of Jerusalem
in the second century,
before Christ.
Or as the Palestinians say,
"Get off our land."
(LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE)
That issue--
That issue is not going away.
Did you see what happened
with the college presidents
this week?
The presidents of the--
of Harvard--
Harvard University
and UPenn and MIT
were hauled before Congress,
and yelled at for good reason,
for refusing to call
the genocide of Jews,
on campus,
bullying or harassment.
Misgender a Jew, get thrown off
for that in a minute.
-(LAUGHTER)
-Not the other thing.
-(APPLAUSE)
-So...
And there may be protests
here this weekend
because the president
is in town.
Isn't that great?
When the president...
-(CHEERING)
-No.
Really? You think that's good?
Are you out on the...
I'll say this.
The only other time in this town
an 81 year old fucks up traffic
is when they're driving a white
Camry in the passing lane.
(LAUGHTER)
No, it's not good
when the president's here.
But the Republicans had
another one of their debates
without Trump.
-This is getting...
-(LAUGHTER)
Now there's four of them
left on the island, and-- and--
(LAUGHTER)
It's just sad.
It's like a battle of the bands
between the other women
in Destiny's Child...
(LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE)
...and the surviving members
of The Doors.
You know, it's just--
But no, there is some crazy
right wing shit out there.
I got to tell you,
the State of New Hampshire
is proposing a ban on abortion
that starts at 15 days
after gestation.
You're not even pregnant yet.
Fifteen days, not weeks, days.
And they asked
the author of this bill,
"What were you thinking?"
And he said, "I don't know,
I never got past second base."
(LAUGHTER)